نقل أنني أشعر
بعدم الارتياح حقًا عندما
يتحدث الجاني عن عنف
غير مناسب وعاكس يجذب
العضو الذي يجب أن أطلب منك الانسحاب
لأنني
لا أستطيع
لأن
هذا الشخص قال أنني سأقلق فقط
في هذه المرحلة في هذه المرحلة
اعتدى عليّ جنسيًا السناتور ثورب
واضطر رئيس الوزراء إلى إقالته
من منصبه ، لذا فإن جعله يتحدث عنه
اليوم هو وصمة عار مطلقة
يجب أن أتصل بك لأمر بأنني سأحيل
ذلك إلى الرئيس الذي أعتقد أنني
أعتقد أنني '  سأحيلها إلى
الرئيس
بدلاً من
مجرد النظر إلى القادة ، فأنا أسري في
عملي هو إحالتها إلى
الرئيس
السناتور فان ، من فضلك أكمل مساهمتك ،
فأنا
أرفض تمامًا أن هذا
البيان المقزز صريحًا
هي مجرد كذبة
وأرفضها
عندما بدأت ، كنت سيناتورًا جديدًا
لأن جميع النساء
اللائي سرن في ممرات هذا
المبنى يعرفن
أنه ليس مكانًا آمنًا ،
فأنت غالبًا ما تكون بمفردك في ممرات طويلة
بلا نوافذ
وفي سلالم مخفية عن المنظر
حيث لا توجد كاميرات ،
كان هذا مكان عملي الجديد ، هذا هو
مكان العمل ، أعلم
أنني أعاني من التعليقات الجنسية وتم
اقتراحه بشكل غير لائق
من قبل رجال أقوياء
تبعني رجل واحد وحاصرني في
بئر سلم وشهد
معظم هذا من قبل الموظفين
والزملاء  أعضاء البرلمان
هناك تفاهمات مختلفة حول
ما يرقى إلى الاعتداء الجنسي ، حيث تم اقتراح
ما حدث لي
بعدوانية
ولمس بشكل غير لائق
كنت أخشى الخروج من باب المكتب ،
كنت سأفتح الأبواب قليلاً
وأتحقق من أن الساحل كان واضحًا قبل أن
أخرج.
تحدثت إلى كبار القادة في الحزب الليبرالي
وتم التأكيد على أن رئيس الوزراء قد تم
إبلاغه
في الوقت الذي كنت مقتنعا فيه أن
الحكومة صدقت أن
تصرفاتهم في نقل مكتب الشخص على الفور
طمأنتني بأنهم يتفهمون
جدية ما عشته
ولا أتمنى  هذا الأمر هو البقاء في
الحزب الليبرالي الذي ناضلت بشدة من أجله ،
لذلك أقبل أنني لن
أجلس بعد الآن في غرفة الحفلة ،
يجب أن يكون هناك
تحقيق ويجب أن يكون هناك تحقيق في هذه
الادعاءات الشائنة حتى يمكن إثبات أنها كاذبة ،
سأفعل.  التعاون الكامل مع
المحققين والإجابة على أي أسئلة
قد تكون لديّهم ويجب على السناتور
ثورب أن يفعل الشيء نفسه